President Trump was reportedly looking
for a new Homeland Security Secretary
The Washington Post says he's decided to
remove secretary Kirsten Nielsen an
administration official tells CBS News
Nielsen is expected to leave by the end
of the year the president's new acting
Attorney General Matt Whittaker is
talking with ethics officials after
Democrats insisted he stay away from
special counsel Robert Muller's Russia
investigation Paula Reed is at the White
House with the newest potential cabinet
shake-up Paula good morning good morning
an administration official tells CBS
News that the president is frustrated
with what he views as Nielsen's
lackluster performance on immigration
enforcement but so far the president is
heeding the advice of his chief of staff
John Kelly and giving Nielson more time
in a statement the Department of
Homeland Security said Nielson who's
only been at the job for less than a
year he's committed to implementing the
president's security focused agenda and
will continue to do so now across town
over at the Justice Department where
President Trump recently fired Attorney
General Sessions even though he was
quite effective on immigration and
enforcement new acting Attorney General
Matthew Whitaker is consulting with
senior ethics officials about whether he
needs to possibly recuse himself from
any cases at the Justice Department and
this comes amid calls from Democrats for
him to step aside from oversight of the
Russia investigation but there is no
legal requirement for Whitaker to follow
their advice whatever it may be now the
president's former personal attorney
Michael Cohen was also in Washington
yesterday to speak with Special Counsel
investigators as part of his continued
cooperation with the Justice Department
and I've spoken with many sources with
knowledge of the Special Counsel
investigation and we do expect new
indictments to be coming as soon as
today
John Paula thank you so much